[Music]
gilbert godfried has died he was 67
years old godfred's team confirmed his
death to e.t in a statement revealing
the comedian died from complications of
a pre-existing abnormal heart rhythm
gottfried's family revealed he died on
tuesday writing on social media quote in
addition to being the most iconic voice
in comedy gilbert was a wonderful
husband brother friend and father to his
two children although today is a sad day
for all of us please keep laughing as
loud as possible in gilbert's honor i'm
just hoping no one throws a chair at me
today and i'll consider it as successful
said a stand-up comic and actor for
decades godfried is perhaps best known
to many as the voice of yago in aladdin
it's it's got romance it's got magic
it's got excitement and if it didn't
have me this would be a quality
production
you got a problem
he appeared in numerous tv and movie
roles including as a saturday night live
cast member if i were able to talk to
him he'd be making a joke about this
godfrey recently opened up to et in the
wake of bob saget's death sharing
memories of his longtime friend when you
did find out about his passing what was
the first thought that went to your mind
about bob just him being a great guy
just like a nice guy
funny and quick
and
i remember like we talk and
we just
crack each other up that was always the
fun part
and
i have another photo
that i always like to put up and i
always like to look at i i was there
with bob and norm macdonald and
jeff ross
and we it was just
we had dinner together and i thought
that was one of the most uh
a night of just laughs
just being outrageous being ridiculous
and just
that was just such a fun night
[Music]
you